and then you guys can wish you guys can
wish rachel happy birthday so put your
messages in now and i will i will bring
those up when we bring rachel on
to say happy birthday to her i know you
guys really like rachel and her insight
and that's that's what i want to ask her
today it's like what
what what does the messaging mean
because she's always focused on
messaging to get democrats some wins in
this country so that we can stave off
this fascist [ __ ]
so what does the messaging mean around
cpac what does the messaging mean around
the war that that putin has started in
ukraine against a sovereign country
trying to across a border and take a
country that is sovereign
a democracy trying to crush democracy
what does that mean and what does it
mean that you gqp the people at the seat
pack are standing on stage grandpa poopy
pants himself that [ __ ] sell out that
[ __ ] treason to sell out a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
standing on stage saying oh well
putin's smart
goddamn he got ukraine for two dollars
worth of sanctions
[ __ ]
vile [ __ ]
and what's more vile than that son of a
[ __ ] standing on stage saying that into
a microphone
then trump
capitulating to putin and his murderous
vile ways
is all the people who were listening to
him say that [ __ ]
they weren't cheering they weren't
clapping
pay no mind they were eating oh that
food was delicious it was so good i mean
god they paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars per plate
what do they care what did they care
people are being killed in ukraine the
salmon was good
you [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
and this is who you've selected q and
honors gq peers trump cultures
you [ __ ] make america great again
trump pumping idiots you've chosen those
people is who you think
you want to rule you
that's the oligarchy the people who were
eating the salmon
as donald trump talked about how
what a great transaction it was for
putin to take ukraine for two dollars
worth of sanctions no matter how many
bodies there are no matter how much
death there is you know how no matter
how much destruction there is what a
great [ __ ] deal that is what a great
[ __ ] deal it is
for putin
that's who you're choosing to be your
oligarchy
you [ __ ] trump pumping fools
that's what you're choosing
because as trump is selling out the
ukrainian people
as he's selling them out on stage
at a fundraiser
they're thinking they weren't cheering
and clapping trump
that's how sick these [ __ ] are
they were thinking oh this salmon is
great are you tasting the salad
how's your wine jan
we paid thousands and thousands of
dollars for this fancy plate of food
forget about forget about the the tyrant
wannabe talking about a murderous
dictator taking over a sovereign country
for two dollars worth of sanctions what
a great deal what a great real estate
deal that is
that's who you [ __ ] idiot trump
humping fools
who think they're going to bring back
jobs and make america great again that's
the oligarchy that you're choosing
to take over our country and be your
[ __ ] leaders to tell you what to do
to be the fascist
regime here the murderous regime here
you wouldn't last two [ __ ]
seconds in russia you wouldn't last two
[ __ ] seconds under putin's rule not
two [ __ ] seconds you weak pieces of
[ __ ]
oh i don't get my whopper i know what i
don't get my whopper because i chose not
to get vaccinated so that people
wouldn't get sick in my community and my
kids wouldn't have we wouldn't have to
worry about schools and disease at
schools oh i don't get my [ __ ]
whopper i don't get my cheesecake
you don't know what [ __ ] liberty is
you have no [ __ ] clue you don't know
what it is and you don't know how to get
it
you have no idea
and if you [ __ ] even if you could
pluck your head out of your ass for two
goddamn seconds and understand that in
this country and other countries and
other democracies around the world
liberty is what we strive for and our
freedoms and our rights deliver us
liberty and it's not [ __ ] perfect
it's not perfect here it's not perfect
in canada and it definitely is not
perfect in ukraine but it's worth
fighting for
it's worth [ __ ] fighting for every
inch every millimeter it's worth
fighting for and i
i am telling you now
that you are on not only the wrong side
of history
but you are on the wrong side of the
world
and you better get straight and you
better [ __ ] you better open your
goddamn eyes
because putin will come for you too he
you will be the first that he comes from
you're the threat
wait until he kills democracy and then
see who he comes for as the threat
it's happened before
not just not just now
it happened during nazi germany
it happened during fascist italy
in japan it happened
don't think it don't don't think that it
won't happen to you you've trump humping
fools so if that's the oligarchy that
you want who is who is oh
fawning over the salmon on the plate
while they listen to the wannabe
dictator talk about how
russia and putin are going in and taking
over a sovereign country a [ __ ]
democracy
because it's a good real estate deal
you sick [ __ ] that is not
america that is not america great again
it never will be it never has been
that's not democracy that's not liberty
that's not freedom
we have a a birthday that we have to
celebrate after the break we are so
excited to have rachel bitkoffer here
i'm sure
she's going to have a few words to say
about about the things that i just
stated
so stay tuned rachel bitcoffer right
after the break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best